[Music]
all right well since we do have a little
bit of time left I have a little bonus
for you I have a little bonus for you
bgl bgl that's right bgl has been making
the rounds on this is another guy's
called master of self
uh this premiered 18 hours ago does 33
views
um because he's a beget
um by the way I have another podcast
that he was on this uh like last week
Friday or Saturday or something what is
your thing
more the better
um so
big a lion by the way if you search for
my YouTube our video comes up number one
uh for him now we're the number one
video for you mark so don't pretend like
you don't know who we are buddy you're
welcome by the way by the way you're
welcome yeah yeah there you go big a
line let's see what we got here coming
up as not just winning but by large
March if like who's this I don't have to
find myself buy these accolades but the
fact that I am recognized is that I'm
not going to say it doesn't feel good
because recognizes what sorry what you
talking about
I I I got tired of these out of context
Clips yeah to tease what you're gonna
just play just play it I mean it's not
even an argument is this the the what do
you call it the buffest the buff is yeah
I mean it's not even an argument about
this is a democracy people voted I said
like there was a an Instagram wide poll
uh seven years running now just they
they open it up to literally the entire
world anybody who has a phone or a
computer you can go on and just vote
who's the best person my name has just
been consistently coming up as not just
winning but by large March if like who's
this
don't buy these accolades but the fact
that I am recognized is that I'm not
going to say it doesn't feel good
because I put in the work you know I
haven't taken any shortcuts you did
steroids you went in the dark web
because he's an end person you took
you're an ass person actually that
that lines up pretty oh
anyway
he um you did take shortcuts you went on
the dark web with exteroids not that I
care but steroids are definitely a
shortcut right like we could agree with
that can we all agree I love when people
go yeah steroids you still got to do the
work and you do yeah but other people do
the work without the steroids so I'm 100
Natty I've never even touched creatine
or BCAAs he's joking no so I'm sorry
that's um he's trying to tell a joke the
guy on the left doesn't get it because
the guy on the left clue doesn't work
out and the guy on the right is of [ __ ]
this is great that's just my path of
building muscle naturally without even a
protein shake
I mean I'm I'm just taking notes all I
can do is see just kids and see how I
can how I can try
he's trying this poor guy is trying okay
just kidding I take Hannah walks yards
uh but I'm very sorry the shoulder
impressed with our conversational
mentorship yeah and your ability and
your interest in being a mentor yeah
being someone that is
because I've been a teacher I didn't
talk like this uh when I was doing years
ago my rapping and when I was doing
comedy sketches I just was I wasn't over
enunciating like this and I wasn't
trying to sound so profound he's read
many books on tape since then I hate him
God doesn't because I've been a teacher
and the teacher of what I didn't like
the structure of San Francisco comedy
College oh he's filling yeah yeah he
fills in he's a teacher's assistant
connect the skin collect the scantrons
elements of and I hate that like Mark
Harley usually does valve replacement
day because it's you know they also do
tire repair there yeah oh that's right
San Francisco comedy college and
automotive center we forgot
that I start to be self-conscious about
me going like it's a feminine
environment but it is being at a school
can kind of I always felt like I was
butting heads with not everybody there
but there's always going to be some sort
of rulemeister a lot of times that's a
woman the problem is is that you know
what Mark Harley does he gets that rule
book right out the window
and then he realized they're in a
warehouse where they film and there's no
windows well he is a maverick
I hate him you see this this is the
rules
you know what it is this is a boring
interview maybe maybe just a quick
little of a hip one maybe a little hip
one he did
this presented by Tiger Tiger whiskey
thick whiskey
except as a reminder to go check us out
on Instagram at Tiger thick whiskey22
the real song the real tiger fig whiskey
yeah what is this oh you haven't seen
this yet who no what is this dobre
Brothers I know the Dober brothers are
the dobre brothers I know it looks like
the Dober Brothers there's the under the
info oh yeah this is yeah Virgie showed
me this I think uh no I think it was
like 40 million views 40 million
probably more now who has a lot yeah she
didn't tag him
because she probably honestly because
I've posted stuff where I haven't talked
so can I can I Virgie would you like to
point out
hey Royce you noticed something weird
about their logo
Under the Influence it's a shoe no no
what what how do they what
what
it's over oh no they overlaid it when
they do the shot because they couldn't
get like a thing
yeah and and I'd like to point out that
they also cleared the space on the wall
for the shelves because they that was
that was planned that was the plan I
don't know the beginning of this set
also it's always good to have a Nike
logo in your logo yeah no that's good
yeah Nike loves that they enjoy that
classic Jordans I know it's not
malicious she's super sweet yeah like
would never do that but as you said it
happens all the time it's really normal
it's just like you know I don't really
think twice about it except as a
reminder to go make sure when you post
other people yeah so this is what life
is over there it's it's a bunch of
people talking about make sure you tag
me on your Instagram post because I want
to get credit for it like
how do you live life like that like it's
so [ __ ] weird all consumption
Advantage all right so um well let's
backtrack a little bit okay I guess we
kind of got off the track a little bit
um I Wish Your Shorts were shorter
because I don't see the head of your
dick yet it's so weird why are your
shorts so short buddy what's going on
with you I feel like you're some kind of
pervert whenever you want to have like
that much close to your genitalia yeah
anytime you want to wear things that are
so skimpy that your dick might just flop
out you kind of wanted to yeah you
wanted to yeah you wanted most guys
don't want this [ __ ] all just flopping
out we usually put a nice set of [ __ ]
box of briefs set of pants over that so
I have to ask is the person on the left
a man or a lesbian from Orange is the
New Black I cannot read that yes for
everyone that doesn't know you X
Gonzalez
X Gonzalez a oh that was Emma because I
hate you yeah what is it that you do
yeah this is the David hog and X
Gonzalez show Under the Influence by the
way watch whenever they motion at each
other their hands disappear behind the
logo that's hilarious and just a little
bit
oh because it's not a green screen so
they can't put it no it's just yeah
you're right I would consider myself an
actor a podcaster I'll give Mark Harley
this he's got great taste and style
wearing one of the uh Kevin Sorbo
collection Hercules special okay but you
got to hear this last part actually I'm
not entirely sure he isn't Kevin Sorbo
drink though I could pound I think I can
drink more than you it's very possible
okay we'll do that damn I was hoping oh
yeah we should I was hoping I was hoping
you were gonna argue an overeating
advantage and yeah alcohol consumption
Advantage all right so um well let's
backtrack a little bit okay I guess we
kind of got off the track a little bit
um for everyone that doesn't know you
this is great what is it that you do get
ready for him to fill out a little IMDb
bio already here we go and just a little
bit about who you are I would consider
myself an actor a podcaster
a screenwriter in the sense that I have
written screenplays and uh some of them
have been produced and I also give notes
to people I continue to do that uh you
know to consult on people's projects
because that's a skill that I think is
super important storytelling I've given
you screenwriting books yeah you know
yeah I know in the future you will
probably be writing your own scripts
just based on the fact that you're so
good at skits and that's a natural
expansion of that
Heath you're a steroid adult gay lion
that's your bio bro no he's a he's a
player we've seen your skits they have
30 views and they suck he's a player in
the industry now we've seen your wraps
they have a bunch of views but you're
the joke Royce I hear you I hear you he
this man you want me to you want to get
mad that man is one degree removed from
Joe Rogan oh yeah no not only that well
two now after the Handler comments after
Brandon's flapping back
but you're you're a bat you carry
Brendan shops bags bro stop it [ __ ]
stop it and by the way but you wear an
adult shirt can you put an adult shirt
on thank you also and I like your
generic USA hat go USA bro you're
[ __ ] everything about you are you not
a fan of the USA this guy tries to do
everything and the net result is always
he's nothing you're nothing you don't
mean anything to anybody I bet that's
probably a soccer hat
he's probably one of those [ __ ]
hipsters it's like yo I enjoy soccer hey
I'm gonna do a soccer player football
I'm gonna do a football pod you want to
come on no